and the right program for prostate enlargement cause urination changes.
Can typically, if you're running the prostate enlargement program, it's going to the idea is
that it's helping to constrict the prostate and to help to shrink the prostate. Now remember,
there's two forms of, there's two reasons for benign hypertrophy. Well, let's say there's two outcomes
in benign prostate hypertrophy. The nine prostate hypertrophy is when the prostate enlarges
and it's not pathological, meaning the person doesn't have cancer of the prostate. If that goes on,
that two things can be taking place. It can just be enlarged due to inflammation and that's when
that right program is going to help decrease that and you're going to probably have, you know,
better urination because of that. If it is enlarged and it's hypertrophy, means the cells have
increased in size, but not pathologically, then there isn't going to be a whole lot that's going to
actually help it. Even the flowmax tends to not really work well, the drugs that are altered tend
to not work well with that, and that's a smaller percentage of people and that's typically over time.
And then the pathological enlargement of the prostate obviously is with cancer of the prostate
and that prostate enlargement frequency program is really not going to help that at all.
So if there's changes for the better, then it's most likely because the inflammation that was at the
prostate, so that's changeable. If you're finding changes for the worse, then it's probably, it's just
probably not helping. And whatever you run a program for a period of time, that's not your program
that I created for you, and it's just, it seems to be making things worse that I would stop running
that program because you might just be getting irritation.